don't miss this amazing opportunity from
Nature's blends to get your finest
premium black seed oil and shilajit to
get that energy levels back up check
them out now
So Yesterday Ronaldo scored a goal and
usually players who score score a goal
celebrate in different ways some people
dance some people do backflips some
people just slide across the pitch but
for some odd reason Ronaldo decided to
do sajdah which is a prostration now we
know from the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu that anytime good news
reached him he would prostrate so we
know from the narration brother sisters
that the news reached him that the
troops had prevailed over their enemy he
was lying with his head on eyeshadow and
his lap and he got up and fell in
prostration and we know for example that
this Sunnah was carried on by Abu Bakr
and Ali when the narrations that we have
here that Abu Bakr may I be pleased with
him frustrated when he heard the news
that muslima
al-kadab had been killed in the Battle
of yamama and reported by side even
Mansoor Ali in Abu Talib frustrated when
he found
right so we know that this is a
prophetic Sunnah that anytime you hear
good news you prostrate and from what we
know what we're told from our teachers
that when you hear good news and you
prostrate it doesn't necessarily have to
be facing the Qibla so to see Ronaldo do
this action shows subhanallah that
inshallah he's getting some sort of
dawah or he's learning about Islam
because he could have celebrated in
different ways which he usually does but
he decided to prostrate his head on the
floor and we asked Allah that he is
guided to Islam and that if I'm not
mistaken he is now playing for a Muslim
team I think I'm not really uh I really
like football but please keep him in
your duas inshallah we hear the news in
the coming months weeks maybe yes that
he has accepted Islam or maybe he has
already accepted Islam may Allah
do share this video to your friends and
family